since ancient times we have sought to
know the human mind
the first scientists and philosophers
asked some of the same questions we
posed today
what do we see and why how do we learn
and why do we forget
where do ideas come from and how do we
generate knowledge
human cognition is the basis for our
accomplishments
yet understanding it has proven elusive
learning more about how we perceive how
we think and how we engage with others
is one of the most important Endeavors
of our time
Yale can take us there
the vision
bold Union of scientific approaches that
lead us to an understanding of cognition
beginning with the basic building blocks
genes molecules and cells mental
processes that build to behavior
algorithms that lend insight into the
inner workings of the brain combine
these components with the diverse
community of scientists and scientific
interests at Yale and we can reveal the
capabilities of the mind we will
understand how our brains grow change
and rewire with the goal of preserving
and enhancing the remarkable flexibility
of the human brain we will describe
brain function with new Precision using
computational approaches to map The
Contours of perception reasoning and
memory we will marry disparate data
types to model human cognition and
advanced machine intelligence
to discover deeper truths learn in new
ways and teach a new generation
the future of Neuroscience begins here
to know together
this is the wusai institute at Yale
University
[Music]